(music)
CARL: Everything just
kind of goes downhill.
I think I just found out
why we can never find
the dog's ball either.
MORGAN: Why?
CARL: Cause it keeps rolling
under the couch over here.
MORGAN: Our poor babies.
CARL: I know.
MORGAN: Always losing
their balls because
our house is sinking.
CARL: Most of the
old float houses around
here are built on logs.
Which, when they're
new is great, they're
super buoyant.
But eventually they
start to lose buoyancy.
Oh my god, this is so
(bleep) far under water.
From the time that I
bought this place, uh,
about three years ago,
I've lost close
to a foot. No good!
And it's gotten a
lot worse just this
last winter.
Get all our
line together.
Start binding these
logs up, get the first
step done.
I think I'd like to
get this done before
we end up like that,
that's the
cautionary tale.
MORGAN: So, which logs
are we cinching out?
CARL: We're going to
start with this one here.
And we're going to
work all the way down
to the end
of that last one that
is floating still.
MORGAN: Okay.
CARL: My plan is I want to
jam some fifteen-gallon
drums underneath
and try and lift the
kitchen end of the house.
First step, I need to
try and strap all the
logs together,
so that when we do jam
barrels under it the whole
thing doesn't blow apart.
I'm not going to be able
to catch this one, but
I think that'll be okay.
Hopefully nothing breaks.
Pull up a little
bit of slack for me.
In Port Protection,
there's an energy
here that has faded.
It's been hard watching
the town get smaller.
Watching, you know,
certain things
kinda fall apart.
That will work! Same
thing, all the way down.
MORGAN: Okay
CARL: Slowly but surely.
I feel a certain
responsibility to
keep it alive,
like to really push,
oh, it's cold, too.
MORGAN: Oh, I know.
CARL: To be successful
and do good.
Show everybody that
you can build a (bleep)
world here still,
you don't have to
go somewhere else
to do that.
Think that's about got it.
Then unhook your
end if you can.
MORGAN: Booyah.
CARL: Oh, yeah.
All right, let's go
get some barrels. Ready?
MORGAN: Yes.
CARL: All right.
SAM: Forty-five, I
think I have to cut
those at a forty-five.
Nothing stopping
me but fear itself.
Looks like a
forty-five to me.
These two sticks of
aluminum are gonna turn
into a small ladder.
We put it on and take it
off the side of a boat.
Two, four, six. Got it.
It'll be good enough
for who it's for.
I've got a unique
opportunity here to find out
what the hell's down
on the bottom of the
ocean around here.
A new friend of mine
wants to go down and
we want to go out
and see if we
can harvest some
sea cucumbers.
Been looking for
a diver for years.
And one finally
moved here.
I'm gonna be his dive
tender. That's not bad.
TROY: Zee flippers.
SAM: I first met Troy
probably two years ago.
He, uh, jumped off
the airplane, I
think he had a,
some kind of a weapon
on his shoulder.
I had my suspicions,
but first conversation,
like I said within
thirty seconds I
went, uh, you know,
it's like never
judge a book by its
cover and since then
we've become good
friends. Troy.
TROY: There he is.
SAM: Look what I got
hot off the press.
TROY: Oh, ho, ho.
SAM: It was a
struggle but I, but I
figured it out.
Figured it out.
TROY: Well, done.
I like it, that's
gonna work great.
SAM: Uh-huh.
TROY: I think it's to
see if we can get us
some creatures.
SAM: Uh-hmm. Yeah.
TROY: Some dinners.
I am originally from
just outside of Seattle
in Kirkland Washington.
For many years, I was a
senior financing consultant
and I've always been very,
very competitive, had
to be number one
everywhere I went
and, uh, that was just
very. Very soul sucking
and draining to me.
What do you think Brutus?
Not a bad way to
start the day.
My dad had been a banker
for almost his whole life.
When my dad was in hospice
I asked him, do you
have any regrets and he,
he didn't even have to
think um, and he said with
tears in his eye that I,
I worked too much and that
really hit me and stuck
with me and started, uh,
pushing me, uh, rolling
down this hill to where
I am now.
The big push now is,
uh, is getting the
cabin up just cause
I am currently
living in a, in a
big canvas tent.
Good boy, go get it!
I know it's gonna be
a lot of work but it's
my never, never land.
Do you want to do a
night dive tonight?
SAM: Ah, I think we'll
practice during the day
light a little.
TROY: It's probably as dark
down there as it is at night.
SAM: You're ready
to go in the water.
KRISTINA: How many
cinder blocks did you end
up with out of your load?
DAVID: Well, I, uh, one
seventy-five, uh, hundred
and sixty of them
made it intact but just
gonna have to pare down what
I was planning on doing.
For the, uh, double wall on
the back of the chimney there,
for, uh, the heat break.
KRISTINA: We gotta get
going on it, garbage
is building up.
DAVID: Roger that baby.
So, what I'm building
basically is a rocket
stove to incinerate trash
and it has three chambers
to it, the first one will
be the hopper,
the burn chamber, the second
will be the actual place
where most of the combustion
happens and I'll have an
eight-foot chimney up
the back that'll be, uh,
four foot by four foot so it
should have excellent draft.
This is gonna be a massive
incinerator that'll actually
burn stuff down to nothing.
I'm gonna be able to share
this incinerator with
the entire neighborhood.
When you make everybody's
life a little easier, if you
just ,you know, lend a hand,
that's what really makes
the community a community.
It's good.
Nice. So those are going
to be the two main
pieces of framework
that the whole thing
is going to ride on.
I think that's going
to work out nicely.
I want this incinerator to
last for the rest of my days.
If this one lasts a couple
of decades, I'll be smiling.
BREANNA: Around here in Port
Protection, we are the next
generation, us younger people.
And so, I definitely
feel the pressure to
be successful.
OLIVER: Hoping it'll
just slide right there.
All right. Sweet.
We bought a bigger boat.
This boat really kind of
solidifies us as fisherman.
It's a whole new horizon
for us to just explore,
so to speak.
BREANNA: We have a loan
that we have to pay.
We're definitely gambling
just everything, we're hoping
that the fish will show up.
And we could just make
this boat work, and it's
gonna be fishy for us.
OLIVER: Basically, we're gonna
go over and, uh, grid our boat.
Finally get to, uh, know what
I paid for it pretty much.
I bought this boat
pretty much sight unseen.
You hope that the person
was honest and sold
you something worthy,
but you never really know
until you see it for yourself.
BREANNA: When we go
out on the grid,
you just set your boat
right down on this platform
and you can see the hull
and see what's going on in
the bottom of the boat,
and you have to
set it just right.
If you set it too far back and
you crush your rudder up into
the hull, that's no good.
OLIVER: Not knowing this
boat and how it, what it
takes to grid, it's, uh,
nerve wracking.
It just kind of might do
me in, as far as business
wise goes.
Be hard to recover from that.
CARL: All right.
Now if you want to swing
the skiff around so
your stern's right here.
MORGAN: Okay.
CARL: We'll start getting
this rigged up and ready.
The float house is slowly but
surely sinking into the ocean
and that's not a good thing.
We are currently attempting
to defy nature and resurrect,
not unlike Lazarus.
All right, that
should hopefully work.
The theoretical idea here is
we pull the barrels really
hard with the skiff
underneath the float house
and they lodge themselves
between the logs.
That's good. In theory.
Theory and practice,
two different things.
I'm gonna go back there
and start levering.
MORGAN: Okay, let me
know when you're ready.
CARL: Dog, go. Come on.
MORGAN: Stay!
Being a newcomer in
Port Protection, I have
a huge learning curve.
I am very confident in
the fact that I can drive
in a straight line
but it's a whole new ball
game pulling a, a barrel
underneath my house.
My biggest worry is when
those barrels go under the
house that its gonna go
through our kitchen
floor and potentially
breaking our house.
CARL: Go whenever
you're ready,
a little more ump to start.
There you go.
MORGAN: (bleep), (bleep). Go!
CARL: Go.
Go, go, go, go, go!
MORGAN: Come on!
Come on!
(bleep).
CARL: Go, go, go, go, go!
Nope.
MORGAN: Okay, you gotta
show me how to do this.
'Cause this is really
frustrating me.
CARL: I'll learn ya.
Morgan really wants to do
well at everything she does.
Now are you gonna be perfect
the first time always?
No, so as long as I'm
there letting her know
that it's, you know,
it's okay to fail a little
bit, we'll figure it all out.
Let's go ahead, go back
to just watch there.
I'm gonna give it a little rip
here and see what happens.
Yup, I lost a handle,
all right.
MORGAN: (bleep).
CARL: He's gone.
See what I got I can
make a handle out of.
I know I got something
around here that'll work.
Ah, I'm thinking just
a cleat, I could bolt a
cleat on there real quick.
If I could find one.
Have any cleats in here?
Everybody's gotta
have a junk pile.
You never really know
what's gonna break.
For me it's a status
symbol. You know, I
see somebody's yard.
I'm like, man, that is a
nice pile of junk you got.
(laughs)
Here we go. That'll work
right there. Perfect.
Bolt it on there and it
should be stronger than ever.
Okay, bolts.
MORGAN: So, you think
this one's gonna hold?
DAVID: I love it when I
can cut a, cut a square
line with a chainsaw.
Tricky, tricky.
KRISTINA: Right there.
DAVID: That should be good.
(sighs)
When you live out here on
the ragged edge it's always
a task and a chore to try
to get rid of all the
waste that we have.
Don't have a garbage
truck pulling up to the
end of the dock here
and taking away all the
crap that you generate.
Hold this on the
inside corner there.
So, the way we've dealt
with garbage is burn it,
bury it, sink it,
or cart it off to town.
This rebar is going to
be spikes to pin, uh, the
timber frame together.
Out here rebar is pretty
cheap, twelve-inch
nails, not quit so much,
so MacGyver moment cut a nice
little head in it, grab your
maul or your sledgehammer
and, oh, look I've got
a twelve-inch nail.
Oh, look I've got
a dozen of them.
See how they work
out for me.
Should be pinned.
Phew, lordy.
We all take extreme joy and
pride in the fact that we
live in the natural world.
And when you see a clump of
trash that's been burned on
the beach and floating around
in the tide line or up
on the beach, it's
heartbreaking.
Leave the world a better
place than you found it.
It's, uh, pretty much
the ethos of most of the
people that live out here.
I think it's actually coming
together pretty well.
Say I'll, uh, fill in the
gravel, so they come up to
level pane here for gravel.
Here's to hoping we can still
keep all our bits and pieces
and Murphy doesn't
rear his ugly head.
SAM: I don't know how
something that's just full
of air could be so heavy.
You ready?
TROY: I think so.
SAM: I'm ready.
Now you're diving.
TROY: All right, rock n roll!
OLIVER: I wanna make
sure that keel sits
about right here,
'cause if it's too far
forward we're going to get
a rudder through our boat.
BREANNA: Perfectly right
in the middle here, maybe
a little bit more forward.
OLIVER: Yeah, hopefully.
SAM: Ugh! This is where
we have to. Ugh!
Give me your hand.
It's a little bit.
TROY: It moved.
SAM: This is like trying
to fit a square peg into
a round hole.
Too tight?
TROY: Yeah.
Ah, there you go, now
you got a grip on it.
SAM: Wimp.
TROY: We'll figure this
out yet.
SAM: That thing is like.
Okay.
Fighting a boa constrictor.
Ugh!
I think the lad needs to
lose about fifteen pounds.
I don't think it should
be that hard. All right,
there you go.
TROY: Finally got to do one.
SAM: Yeah.
The optimum outcome from this
whole diving exercise for me
would be a mess of sea
cucumbers, 'cause I
haven't had them for
twenty-five years.
And actually, I've been
craving them ever since.
But without having a diver
living here, you're S-O-L.
Ugh!
We're having some fun.
And he's away.
He's off to the races.
This is a first for me
and seeing is how I'm
not a diver
and I don't have a
bunch of gear,
if something does happen to
him when he's down there
he's, he's on his own.
OLIVER: It's one AM.
Parking on the grid here at
night because, uh, the
tides are gonna be kind of
small tomorrow afternoon
and I'm not sure if I'll be
able to get on and off.
Sometimes, the only time
that presents itself is right
in the middle of the night.
It's not optimal, but
it's just what we got.
This is the first time that
we've grid-ed this boat, so.
Little nervous about it.
A lot going on when
you grid this thing.
You gotta make sure the
pilings are just right,
everything's lined up,
don't want to smash the
rudder with the weight
of the own boat.
I don't want to be
someone that someone
hears about one day.
Little nervous.
I don't know where the
beach is over here.
BREANNA: What's going on?
OLIVER: There it
is, we're close.
Slow down a little
bit here, whoa.
Yeah, real close. Whoa.
Pull the bow in.
Oh, ouch.
Holy moly.
I gotta get out there. Find
something to tie it to.
Don't really have
much to tie it to.
All right.
BREANNA: I'm a little
anxious about all this.
It's definitely gonna
settle, uh, as the tide goes
out, so we just don't know
how it's going to settle.
Bad things can happen
where a boat will shift
and then it can roll
completely over so,
we'll see. It's
probably not gonna be
a lot of sleep.
OLIVER: Let's see
what we got, huh?
Careful coming off this
ladder, Breanna, it's
real sketchy, okay?
BREANNA: It's a new boat and
until you get the boat on the
grid and see what's going on,
you really don't
know what you've got.
You're hoping that the money
that you've already paid
you don't have to put
any more into it.
How's it look down there?
How's it look?
I'm wondering, curious.
OLIVER: It's, it's, it's
(bleep) perfect dude,
it's better than I could
have hoped for man.
BREANNA: Awesome.
OLIVER: Yeah, I mean it's.
BREANNA: I'm gonna
come check it out.
OLIVER: Hell, yeah.
BREANNA: Wow, it
does look great.
Sweet!
Yeah, it looks like he
just freshly painted it.
OLIVER: Man, woo, yeah
see that's pretty much
what needs to be done,
the zinc's gotta be replaced.
They're all ate away and
that one there's kinda
gone and that bugger there.
But, boy, and I think we
got what we paid for, man.
We definitely got a
good deal here really.
Well, let's get cracking man.
BREANNA: Sweet.
OLIVER: Hoping I can
get this done before the
tide comes in around me.
TROY: I probably have
almost a thousand dives
under my belt.
But that doesn't mean
anything. It really is
a different world.
You know, we're not meant
to be forty feet underwater.
You can never get
overconfident about
diving at all.
SAM: Twenty-five years ago, my
buddy spent, I'm going to say
fifteen minutes down there.
Came up with a nice bag of
them hanging off his belt.
And we had a hell
of a good feed.
Fond memories.
TROY: I get in the
water here, visibility
is not awful.
But I see there's sand,
crushed shells everywhere.
Looks like the otters had
a field day with, uh, just
about everything down there.
SAM: He's been down
there, uh, oh, half
hour now anyways.
I'm expecting that, uh,
seeing how he hasn't pulled
on this thing sooner
probably pretty slim pickings.
Oh, I hear the ladder
rattling. There he is.
TROY: Oh, God.
SAM: There he is.
What'd you see?
TROY: Definitely you
could tell the sea
otters have been here.
A lot of eaten mussels and,
uh, yeah. Shells everywhere.
They have, they have been
feasting here, no doubt.
Not a single sign of sea
cucumber. You hear that?
SAM: Yeah. I hear that.
TROY: Oh, yeah.
SAM: Yeah. Steady stream.
It's coming out of this
one fitting right here.
TROY: That explains the
air going pretty quick.
Huh. It's not easy to
get this stuff out to the
dock shop or get it back.
It is not quick.
It's not cheap.
SAM: It's a bunch of BS. BC.
TROY: Yeah. (inaudible)
BREANNA: Yeah, it just
needs a little hose down.
OLIVER: These are our
zincs right here that
we gotta replace.
I'm hoping that everything
works out for them.
Zincs are basically
grounded into the
steel here.
It just is where the
electrical stuff that's
like where the ground of
your batteries hooked to
is all into this stuff
it's all connected.
And it just basically is a
sacrificial metal so that
stuff like the prop
and the shaft and the rudder
doesn't get ate away.
And this is the last zinc.
Just in time as the
water is coming up.
Oh. Doesn't fit.
Hey, Breanna?
BREANNA: Yeah?
OLIVER: You wanna
come on down here?
BREANNA: Okay.
OLIVER: So, we have kinda
something going on here,
we gotta try and make
this bugger fit where
this one came off of.
It's kind of
presenting a challenge.
It could just come off and
then my whole shaft would have
no electrolysis protection.
BREANNA: It'll get pitted.
It'll start getting eaten
away by the electrolysis.
OLIVER: Yeah. And
it's something,
this is easily a
thousand dollar or more
propeller right here,
and I can't afford
that right now.
All my money right now has
to go into boat payments.
With this tide coming in,
you think I have enough
time to grab the grinder?
BREANNA: If you're
fast, I think we have
a little bit of time.
I understand.
OLIVER: Right. And, well,
if I can find it, and find
my cutting wheel and stuff.
BREANNA: All right.
OLIVER: Definitely the tides
starting to come back in,
and if we don't get off
the beach on this tide,
we're going to be stuck
there for quite a while.
Not gonna be good.
DAVID: Yeah, just be good
and ginger on the corners.
Go one at a time instead of
trying to two hand them,
if it'd be easier,
'cause like I say,
we got no margin for
error when it comes to
material loss.
I've done some
construction but most of
it is self-taught and, uh,
the nature of the beast is
often necessity, it's just
how it is.
We're getting
somewhere now, darling.
Um, one, two, three,
four, five.
Don't like that much.
That's sitting
high in the middle.
Can't have that going on.
KRISTINA: Why is
that happening?
DAVID: Uh, there might be,
uh, a little too much
gravel humped up on
the middle there on one side.
KRISTINA: That's not
gonna work on the chimney.
DAVID: Right. Yeah.
All right.
This simply will not do.
The, the whole, the whole base
plate is, is a little bit, uh,
convex and I need it to be
concave so that the,
instead of spreading out
as I build the chimney up
it pushes in on itself.
I'm gonna have to figure
out what to do about you.
Hm.
DAVID: All right, baby.
So, to make sure
the chimney doesn't start
trying to split apart on us.
I'm gonna jack this up here,
I got some nice pressure
treated material there
that's actually a wedge
KRISTINA: Okay.
DAVID: And as soon as you
lift this up, I'm gonna try
to pound that into the, uh,
the very edge of the, uh,
the framework on both sides
and that should be enough to,
to get the concave
form off the base.
Yeah. Definitely already
got some weight on her.
Sweet, I don't
have to pound crap.
Okay. Let her down.
KRISTINA: There it is.
DAVID: Oh, yeah. Look at
that. It's all this brick.
Don't you love it when a plan
eventually comes together?
OLIVER: The tide is coming
in kind of quick right now,
and I'm rushing
against the clock.
All righty. Grab one of
these for extra just in
case, always be prepared.
All right. Let's
get out of here.
Since it was our first
time griding the boat,
we didn't really know
what zincs to buy.
So, I kinda just guessed
and got what I figured
you know, would work.
I'm just going to buzz off a
little bit of this end here.
One of the props didn't
really fit right,
so I'm definitely
concerned about that one.
The prop is an important part
of the boat, you know, if
that starts to get, you know,
eaten away with
electrolysis, it's going
to be an expensive fix.
And so I'm hoping
everything works out.
All right. Breanna, just
hang on to this bugger
like that, okay?
I'm going to cut off on
this thing down here.
All right.
All right, it's rough
enough to go on my boat.
Even it was too nice it
wouldn't know what to do.
Okay. With the tide coming
in around my ankles,
I just have to roll around
with what I got right now.
BREANNA: Oh.
OLIVER: Cool. Yeah,
sweet man.
Well, definitely got it on,
and definitely is tight.
So far, I'm a happy camper.
BREANNA: At the nick of time.
OLIVER: Heck yeah.
Only thing left to do is
get off this thing and go
catch a fish.
BREANNA: Let's go
see what it's got.
OLIVER: Come on, dogs.
Load up!
All aboard?
BREANNA: Yup.
OLIVER: Moment of truth.
Oh, we're moving.
Hell yeah.
All right.
There's sun shines on a dog's
ass every now and again.
SAM: Oh, look at that.
TROY: Oh, yeah.
SAM: Well, you cannot hear
it but you can sure as
hell see it.
I think you got a
faulty hose here.
But we can put a
band aid on it.
This is a self-fusing tape;
it fuses itself together.
I patched a garden
hose with it once.
TROY: Let's try it on
the life support system.
It's gonna be a thing
where I'm gonna have to
keep a much, much better eye
on the pressure gauge.
I mean it doesn't
matter if you've dove
hundreds of thousands of
times your next dive's your
most important dive,
I take very, very,
very seriously.
SAM: I wanna give this
a good soaping down now.
TROY: Now that
looks, looks good.
SAM: Well.
TROY: Horseshoes
and hand grenades.
CARL: Okay, let's
try that again.
MORGAN: Okay.
CARL: Oh lordy, lordy,
lordy, look who's forty.
Okay, I'm gonna go for it.
MORGAN: Give her hell, baby.
CARL: Oh, I hope this works.
Keep this whole
thing from sinking.
SAM: We should be good right
here, just stop right here.
TROY: Time to start
gearing up. And then
let's get wet.
Although Sammy science
works ninety-nine-point
nine percent of the time,
this is my life we're dealing
with here with this air, so,
we don't want to be going
down super deep with, uh,
with a hose that's not
quite at a hundred percent.
SAM: He's still breathing.
I'm not a diver.
I catch things with a hook
and line, maybe a gill net.
The idea of going in there
and trying to get something
with my bare hands.(laughs)
I have a philosophy.
Stay out of the water.
Been in the water a
long time.
Gotta be just about
out of air now.
I know.
Papa's getting
farther from the boat.
SAM: There are some
little pocket caves down
here along this cliff.
It is aways down and
hopefully he can make it
to those.
There are little pockets
of life I'm hoping the sea
otter can't deal with
because it's on the
wrong spot.
He's coming back.
I thought he might be
coming up with the basket,
by God he is.
TROY: Whoa-ho!
SAM: What did you get?
TROY: We got a little one.
SAM: Well, oh I see him.
That is what you call pretty
thin soup, pretty thin soup.
TROY: That's not going
to fill the freezer.
SAM: No, it's not.
These are, uh, beautiful
creatures actually.
They get much larger,
they get that big around
and that long
and that's the kind you
are really looking for.
This one here is just a
baby. That would be not
even a snack.
TROY: Well, we didn't
get skunked, but we're.
SAM: Well, that's
a skunk in my book.
If you had a dozen of them,
you know we'd be talking,
that would have been let's
have some sea cucumber
strips for supper.
Well, the trips pretty much
over, we're out of air.
Let's see, our total take
was one sea cucumber,
I think we just got our
asses handed to us.
TROY: Burn me please.
Okay, don't burn me.
SAM: Is that pretty
much too hot?
TROY: No, it's all right.
It just feels like I
peed down my leg though.
SAM: I am looking forward
to in the next ten years
becoming somewhat
of an expert about the
dive industry.
Now that I have someone
who lives in the community
and it's always good,
you know to have a
young feller around.
Especially when he
has a sense of humor.
You know your water
rolls of your head like a
duck, you're waterproof.
TROY: You got to get
your Troy's in a row.
Having a relationship
with the old timers out
here is huge
and I lucked out on
meeting the right people
out here that you know,
kind of taken me under the
wing like Sam has and uh.
I think Port Protection
has a lot more bounty
for us to get, I think
this is the tip of
the iceberg.
SAM: Well, I think Troy
this is probably just the
beginning of this operation.
TROY: Well, we literally
got our feet wet.
SAM: Sure.
MORGAN: Come on, come on!
Go, go, go!
It went straight to
the front.
CARL: Woo-hoo!
(bleep) yeah, that worked!
Did it do what it wanted to do?
MORGAN: Well, it's there
and it's not gonna move.
CARL: Oh, (bleep). (laughs)
Let's do a couple more?
MORGAN: Yeah.
CARL: All right.
Oh, lordy.
MORGAN: It went down.
CARL: Awesome!
MORGAN: Woo!
CARL: Looks like we
might have come up
another tiny little bit.
MORGAN: Yeah.
CARL: Port Protection
has changed a lot since
I was young.
And away we go.
I have seen a lot of
people die, a lot of
people move away.
MORGAN: Under!
CARL: Fishing has gotten worse
progressively, so there's not
really a strong draw.
I am hoping this is
the last barrel we
have to stick in here.
Last one's a charm.
Where we're going?
I have no idea but
I'm gonna be here you
know, for the long haul.
Building up our empire.
Getting us where we
want to be.
MORGAN: We did it!
CARL: Success.
MORGAN: Woo!
(laughs)
CARL: I think with the
barrels under there we've
increased the longevity
of the house by five
to ten years maybe
and maybe when I move
out and get over to
the new property,
we get to pass that on to
somebody else that needs
a quick starter house.
Let's, uh, clean up and
see if anything rolls
around the house now.
Looking pretty level.
(laughs)
OLIVER: Four and
a half fathoms.
It's definitely exciting to
be able to get some hooks
in the water.
And, uh, I'm really excited
to get some king salmon.
The tides are just right.
This is, uh, sport
trolling, it's not open
for commercial right now
but getting the boat out
and testing is what's
important.
BREANNA: I'm not gonna be
satisfied until we got
some fish on the deck
that's for sure.
There's a lot riding
this season, um,
with our new investment
with this new boat.
We have a bill now that
we have to pay so we're
gonna have to fish hard.
Just hoping that we're gonna
get something out of it and
be able to like stay afloat.
OLIVER: Hey, dude!
Dammit, dude!
Took my flasher.
Oh, he is laughing at me.
That son of a (bleep).
BREANNA: I can tell Oliver
really wants to catch a fish
like really bad and he gets
really in fish fever kind of.
Just like any fisherman, they
get very like, just sensitive.
(Laughter)
OLIVER: These are the troll,
I got my lines in the water,
this would be a perfect time
to, uh, to go check my, uh,
what we got going on here?
Yeah. I might actually
have something on it.
Oh, no. Dude!
It's about like the equivalent
of catching a boot.
I caught a lifejacket strap.
Starting to wonder about
the luck on this boat now.
Man, I had high hopes
for this summer.
More fish than this.
There's one of them.
Dude, what (bleep)
is going on here?
We're just probably the,
weirdest day I've ever
had trolling in my life.
Maybe move and go try
trolling someplace else.
It doesn't seem like
there's much in the bay,
usually after a couple passes
one will bite or it won't.
Oh!
That might be a fish, man!
OLIVER: Oh, it is a fish!
We got a fish. Neutral.
Go in neutral! Go in neutral!
We got a fish!
(bleep) He's right there.
Woo!
Come on buggers.
Make sure we get a good
position here, might
run, he's a nice one.
Babe, we don't need
to pull in.
No, don't, don't, don't
go to him, let him come
to you, okay?
Closer! Uh, no.
Oh, straight up, pull it
straight up, oh, there we go.
BREANNA: Damn,
that's (bleep) up!
OLIVER: Over here! Yes.
BREANNA: There we
go, we got one.
OLIVER: Woo!
BREANNA: Our boat's fishy!
OLIVER: The boat's
catching man, woo!
I feel like I caught a fish
man, I feel like a stud dude.
Hell yeah! Hell yeah!
Blood on the deck,
there it is, woo!
BREANNA: Awesome.
OLIVER: (bleep) yeah!
Boat seems to be fishy.
Glad to see it catch something.
Now it's just a matter
of getting into the
commercial season
and seeing how everything
works out for the long run.
Let's go prepare a din-ar.
Din-ar.
BREANNA: Sushi.
That's what I want.
OLIVER: The first of
many, first of many.
DAVID: Oh, yeah,
that's gonna be fun.
Baby doll, I'm
gonna need a hand.
KRISTINA: Oh, yes.
DAVID: Grab it.
These cinder blocks are about,
uh, thirty-six pounds apiece.
Man, this is gonna be
a pain in the yarbles.
All right.
Mother glory.
When you gotta go over your
head and lift them way out
when you're awkwardly
standing it can be a bit
of a challenge.
There was this guy that
built a tower back in Italy
that's called the leaning
tower and, uh, I really
don't want to go there.
I got my darling right
underneath me, man, and I
definitely don't want to drop
anything on her head.
So, it's a matter of taking my
time, not only do I have a very
slim window as far as, uh,
materials go but, uh, safety
out here is always paramount.
KRISTINA: One more.
DAVID: Oh, jeez.
Yeah, I feel.
KRISTINA: Why is
that the heaviest?
DAVID: I'm feeling it in
my wrists that's for sure.
Oh, last bricker.
God, I love that one.
Ready for the
maiden voyage baby?
KRISTINA: Yes.
DAVID: There's
always uncertainty.
You never know exactly how
things are gonna pan out,
especially when you're flying
by the seat of your pants.
KRISTINA: Light this up.
DAVID: Right on.
Oh yeah, there we go.
The draft's already
starting to pull it.
Yeah. This thing is
going to incinerate.
When a plan actually
does come together,
and it works out the way
you hope it does there is
no better feeling
in the damn world. What
do you think, doll?
Was it worth hauling
all that gravel and
that heavy ass brick up?
KRISTINA: Yes. It was.
DAVID: I think so too.
This infrastructure it'll be
big enough, it'll last, and
I know we're gonna have
plenty of people coming
up, lighting a fire.
Man, this is an exquisite
addition to the back forty.
Go see if we can't
collect a little bit more?
KRISTINA: Okay, sounds good.
CARL: I did this last
night after we got done.
(Laughter)
No more rolling!
MORGAN: No more rolling.
CARL: No more rolling.
We're not going to find
weird (bleep) under the
couch anymore.
MORGAN: Moving here in the
beginning was something I
really had to get used to.
But it's been such a wild
ride, and I'm lucky to say
I have the best partner
in the world to help
me out with these.
SAM: Villages in Alaska
are, are losing their
populations.
Port Protection is
no different.
TROY: Dinner is served.
SAM: Yeah.
So, it's real important
for you know people like
me to pass along
as much as I can to
these younger fellers.
TROY: I want more.
SAM: I'll wrestle
you for the rest.
(Laughter)
BREANNA: Having put my
roots here in Alaska is
really important to me,
and I definitely think
that this new boat
is going to help us keep
living this lifestyle.
Maybe even have kids.
It'll be big enough,
it'll be safe.
DAVID: You've only got
yourself and your
neighbors to count on,
it's important to. Pull
up what slack you can.
This is the MB up in Baker,
just letting everybody know
I got my incinerator built
today so if, uh, anybody needs
to get rid of some refuse
give me a holler back
on seventy-four.
I wear quite a few hats
around here, I chair
the community council,
volunteer on EMS and fire
but, uh, wouldn't want it
any other way 'cause
I know that, uh, my
neighbors are pulling
slack too.
Look at that fire pit!
Captioned by
SubTitlePro LLC